G
THAT MATTERS.
YOUR SACRIFICE IS BUT A SMALL
PRICE TO PAY.
HERE WITH THE ACTION NOW, AUTHOR
OF WHAT IS GOING TO BE A VERY
IMPORTANT FAKE BOOK DEFEATING
BIG GOVERNMENT SOCIALISM, SAVING
AMERICA'S FUTURE.
BY THE WAY, Amazon.com.
WE WILL PUT IT UP ON
Hannity.com AS WELL.
THAT REALLY IS WHAT WE ARE
BATTLING AGAINST HERE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ACTUAL
POLICY, IT IS SOCIALISM, IS IT
NOT?
>> WHAT YOU HAVE IS A
COMBINATION OF BIG GOVERNMENT
SOCIALISM AND A KIND OF WOKE AND
A SECULAR RELIGION.
THE PROBLEM THAT BIDEN HAS IS
THAT HE CAN'T BREAK LOOSE FROM
IT.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW, MOST PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY KNOW THERE ARE WAYS
TO SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS THAT
MAKE LIFE BETTER FOR AMERICA AND
THEY MAKE AMERICA A STRONGER
COUNTRY.
ALL OF THOSE SOLUTIONS JUST
DRIVE THE BIG GOVERNMENT
SOCIALIST AND THE LEFT CRAZY.
SO BIDEN SITS THERE AND DOES
MORE OF WHAT DOESN'T WORK AND
THEN TRIES TO BLAME A PUTIN OR
SOMEBODY, THE BIG CORPORATIONS.
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMEBODY ELSE.
I WAS STRUCK THE OTHER DAY THAT
THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY MIGHT BE
CALLED FROM THE BASEMENT TO THE
BY CENTRAL, BECAUSE IF YOU WATCH
HIM, HE SPENDS EVERY WEEKEND
BICYCLING.
HE'S NOT ENGAGED.
HE'S NOT HELPING THE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE.
HE CERTAINLY NOT SOLVING OUR
PROBLEMS.
HE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE EVEN AWARE
OF HOW BAD THE BORDER IS TO
OURSELVES.
THE CRIME PROBLEM, WHICH PROPPED
UP AGAIN IN NEW YORK TODAY IN A
VERY VIVID AND POWERFUL WAY
DOESN'T SEEM TO AFFECT HIM.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, WHAT KIND OF
TOTAL COCOON ARE THEY LIVING
UNDER THAT THEY DON'T REALIZE --
WE ARE DRIFTING TOWARDS A
DISASTER.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO FIRE HIM.
>> EVEN ON COVID, THEY RAN OUT
OF TESTS OVER CHRISTMAS.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
THAT'S ALMOST AN IMPOSSIBILITY
AS WE ENTER YEAR THREE.
THE ECONOMY, I READ THE NUMBERS,
A DISASTER.
ENERGY POLICIES -- IT WAS $2.42
A GALLON UNDER DONALD TRUMP.
I PAY FOR 79 A GALLON THIS
WEEKEND.
HE LEFT IT AT 1.4.
HOLD PRICE IS HIGHEST EVER,
WHOLESALE PRICES, 11.2.
DONALD TRUMP LEFT IT AT 1.6.
THESE ARE NOT SMALL CHANGES.
EVERY MAJOR ECONOMIST IS NOW
SUGGESTING WE ARE GOING TO HIT A
RECESSION AND IT IS GOING TO BE
BAD.
THE ONLY WAY THAT I SEE THAT
THEY CAN GET OUT OF THIS IS GO
BACK TO TRUMP'S POLICIES.
WE KNOW THAT IS NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> AND THAT'S THE WHOLE PROBLEM.
EVERYTHING WHICH WORKS, WHICH IS
WHAT RONALD REAGAN DID, WHAT WE
DID WITH THE CONTRACT WITH
AMERICA AND WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DID COME ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE
OBVIOUS.
AND WE KNOW THEY WORK.
BUT IF YOU ARE IN THE SECULAR
RELIGION OF THE LEFT AND YOU GET
TOGETHER WITH YOUR FRIENDS AND
DO YOU THINK THAT FIGURING OUT
WHICH PRONOUN TO USE IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN SOLVING CRIME OR
YOU FIGURE OUT THAT BRAINWASHING
THIRD-GRADERS ABOUT TRANSGENDER
BEHAVIOR IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
CONTROLLING THE BORDER, JUST GO
DOWN THE LIST.
BY ANY HISTORIC STANDARDS, THESE
PEOPLE ARE CRAZY.
I DON'T THINK THEY CAN CHANGE
BECAUSE I THINK THEY ARE CRAZY
AND I THINK IF BIDEN TRIED TO
CHANGE, THEY WOULD'VE RUBBED
OVERNIGHT AND YOU WOULD HAVE AN
EXTRAORDINARY CIVIL WAR.
>> Sean: THEY HAVE JOE'S
APPROVAL RATING AT 33%.
THEY HAVE HIS APPROVAL WITH
INDEPENDENCE AT 26%.
RECENT POLLS HAVE SHOWN A
DEMOGRAPHICS WHICH OF
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND
HISPANIC AMERICANS TOWARDS THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THEN YOU'VE GOT THE BAD ECONOMY,
THAT IS IMPACTING EVERYBODY.
THE DISASTROUS AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAW AND FRANKLY A LACK OF
URGENCY AS IT RELATES TO UKRAINE
IN PROVIDING AMMUNITIONS TO BEAT
BACK VLADIMIR PUTIN'S FORCES
WITHOUT ONE AMERICAN BOOT ON THE
GROUND.
>> LET ME START BY POINTING OUT
THAT WHEN HILLARY CLINTON
OFFERED ADVICE, HER HUSBAND LOST
53 SEATS AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN 40 YEARS, THE REPUBLICANS
CONTROLLED THE HOUSE.
THAT WAS THEIR FIRST TERM.
WHEN BARACK OBAMA LAST WEEK
OFFERED HIS ADVICE, HE LOST 63
SEATS AND LOST CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE.
SO HAVING THEM OFFER ADVICE ON
THE ELECTION I THOUGHT WAS
TERRIFIC AND I HOPE THAT THEY
TAKE THEIR ADVICE.
IT WOULD BE A TOTAL DISASTER.
THE POLL IS PRETTY OBVIOUS.
I FILLED UP MY TRUCK THE OTHER
DAY AND IT WAS ABOUT $85, I HAVE
A HYBRID.
SO MINE IS SLIGHTLY CHEAPER.
SHE PAID $91 TO FILL UP HER CAR.
APPEARED TO GO THE GROCERY STORE
AND THE PRICES OF ALL GONE UP.
ONE OF THE FOLKS I WORKED WITH
SAID THEY ARE NOT EVEN GOING TO
TRY TO BUY A STAKE IN THE NEAR
FUTURE BECAUSE IT IS ABSURD LEAD
TO EXPENSIVE.
WE HAVE AN AVIAN FLU THAT IS
LEADING THE KILLING OF NEARLY
MILLIONS OF CHICKENS.
WHEAT IS GOING TO GO UP
DRAMATICALLY.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AROUND, IF YOU
ARE A NORMAL EVERYDAY PERSON AND
YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO BELIEVE WHATEVER
BRAINWASHING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" OR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" PUT OUT
THIS MORNING, YOU GO IN AND YOU
ARE SEEING REAL PROBLEMS MAKING
ENDS MEET.
AND YOU START HEARING ABOUT A
RECESSION.
A RECESSION IN THIS ECONOMY
COMING RIGHT AFTER COVID WOULD
BE EXTRAORDINARILY PAINFUL.
AND ONE PERSON THEY ARE GOING TO
BLAME FOR IT.
THAT IS JOE BIDEN.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO OUT
THERE AND SIT AND SCRATCH THEIR
HEAD AND THINK GEE, I WONDER HOW
THIS HAPPENED?
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BELIEVE
THAT PUTIN DID IT.
>> THAT BRINGS US TO YOUR BOOK,
DEFEATING BIG GOVERNMENT
SOCIALISM OUT IN JUST A COUPLE
OF WEEKS.
I MEAN, THAT REALLY CAPTURES THE
MOMENT THAT WE ARE IN BECAUSE
THAT IS THE IDEOLOGICAL BATTLE
THAT WE ARE NOW GOING THROUGH AS
A COUNTRY, ISN'T IT?
>> SURE.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
SELECTION SET FIREBALLS AMONG
EVERYBODY ON THE HARD LEFT
BECAUSE HE WAS A REAL CHANGE
AGENT.
HE WAS MOVING US BACK TOWARDS
THE AMERICA THAT WORKS.
YOU WERE POINTING OUT THE
NUMBERS A WHILE AGO, THEY ARE
OUTSTANDING THE THINGS HE
ACHIEVED IN FOUR YEARS DESPITE
THE ELITE MEDIA, DESPITE THE
FBI, DESPITE THE WHOLE
BUREAUCRACY FIGHTING HIM.
HE NONETHELESS ACHIEVED AMAZING
THINGS.
AND THE COUNTRY WAS IN PRETTY
GOOD SHAPE JUST BEFORE COVID
HEAD.
I THINK OF TRUMP WAS STILL IN
CHARGE, THEY WOULD BE BACK IN
VERY GOOD SHAPE RIGHT NOW.
WE KNOW HOW TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS.
AND I THINK WHAT I TRY TO POINT
OUT AND DEFEATING BIG GOVERNMENT
SOCIALISM, THIS IS A MOMENT NOT
JUST TO TALK ABOUT THE
INCOMPETENCE OF A HANDFUL OF
LEADERS.
THIS IS A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THE VERY CORE VALUES THEY
BELIEVE IN DO NOT WORK.
THAT THIS IS A VALUES AND
PHILOSOPHY PROBLEM AND THAT
THOSE FOLKS HAVE GOT TO BE
DEFEATED DECISIVELY AND GET
AMERICA BACK ON THE RIGHT TRACK
CREATING JOBS, STABLE MONEY,
CONTROLLING THE BORDER,
CONTROLLING CRIMINALS, DOING
SOMETHING LIKE FAVORING THE
INNOCENT VICTIM OVER THE
CRIMINAL.
THAT SEEMS LIKE IT IS COMMON
SENSE UNLESS OF COURSE YOU ARE
ON THE WOKE LEFT AND YOU HAVE
SOME REALLY WEIRD IDEA ABOUT HOW
THE WORLD WORKS.
>> Sean: IT WELL SAID.
THEY COULD PROBABLY USE A LESSON
OR MAYBE TAKE A PAGE OUT OF
1994.
I WAS THERE THAT NIGHT WHEN YOU
DID BECOME SPEAKER.
I WAS THE MC.
AND IT MAY BE TIME FOR PUTTING
THE SIGNATURE TO PAPER AND
PROMISE WHAT YOU WILL DO IF
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.